did you ever hear their bonds song sorry
verbatim song
billy eyelashes oh i don't know adele's
the best bonds adele was great adele was
great and even though it wasn't a very
good uh tom jones thunderball was
fantastic absolutely yeah 100 i don't
know the billy no billy alice boss
just like
i wanna put the gun in my mouth
i don't wanna she's so depressing yeah i
was talking i was talking to a friend
about this and he's like girl she's
super i was like she's gonna go like
she's so depressing who listens she goes
you've got a billion plays and my wife
is like so and he goes that's a million
that's a million a thousand million
plays i'm like did you just math explain
what a billion is to my wife yeah it
happens yeah you kick his ass yeah i did
yeah good you should i threw him in the
lake i don't think he got out you don't
mathsplain
to my wife
she wanted want to be masterplan too she
would have gone to the stem field but
she doesn't just like women
statistically don't